welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in the mandalorian has premiered on
Disney Plus with a very promising Star
Wars spin-off series that hits the right
notes of the used futurism that's
actually a long time ago in the violent
Western imagery of the original trilogy
while introducing some major tie-ins to
the Star Wars history we thought we knew
we may never see Petra Pascal's face in
the show and that might be a good thing
I'm sure he wants some protection after
what happened to him in Game of Thrones
let's break down chapter 1 of the
mandalorian to explain what's going on
with the series how it connects to these
Star Wars universe that bombshell twist
ending and some interesting details that
you might have overlooked spoiler
warning if you have not seen the
Mandalorians first episode yet
okay the pilot opens with the
Mandalorians seeking his bounty a myth
role played by Horatio Sanz he's in a
bar being harassed by a group of
trawlers they speak Huttese the language
of Jabba the Hutt the one with stache is
former MMA fighter tape Fletcher who
also had roles in John wick and Breaking
Bad this series is set five years after
the Battle of Endor and returned the
Jedi or the year nine ABY after the
Battle of Yavin it's also four years
after the Empire's final military defeat
at the battle of jakku
so the remnants of the empire are now
split into fragments with stormtroopers
serving increasingly weakening regional
governors as the new republic is forming
under the leadership of figures like mon
mothma
and leia organa now the music throughout
this episode is a bold departure from
the classic vog marion orchestral swells
of john williams
if these flute instrumentals sound
familiar they were all composed by love
the goranson who composed similar music
with a full of flute to her black
panther the Mandalorian that's a
mouthful let's just use the travelers
name for him mando takes out these
trawlers they asked if his armor is best
scar and they scrape it with a knife
best scar is the famous precious metal
of the planet Mandalore it's a metal
known for its powerful durability to
things like blaster fire mando tells the
myth Rojo I can bring you an alarm or a
cold he's saying Dead or Alive but
ultimately he does bring him in cold
frozen in carbonite there lift back to
the shipyard is summoned by hey COO Baz
with a flute another member of the
kuvasz species showed up as an Imperial
spy in the original Star Wars and Mos
Eisley mando hates droids it's actually
similar to the cantina bartender in a
new hope who refused to serve droids
who actually learned in literary
material that that was because the
bartender's parents were killed by
droids during the Clone Wars and those
reasons are actually pretty similar
flashbacks reveal a past attack on
Mandalore in which Clone Wars era super
battle droids scene in Revenge of the
Sith
attack his Mandalorian tribe when he was
a boy a crappier human-piloted speeder
floats up driven by a character played
by Brian Posehn I love how peace falls
off it this guy ends up getting eaten by
a Ravan AK bursting out from under the
ice like an orca eating the seal mando
escapes and as they depart the planet
the myth Rahl snips around the ship
saying was hoping to be free for life
life BAE is a real deep cut to Star Wars
lore it's from the Star Wars TV holiday
special in which Chewbacca goes home to
his family for life day the Star Wars
equivalent to Christmas and life day is
now apparently cannon myth Roth sees a
row a past family frozen in carbonite
including a Rodian when Darth Vader
froze han Solo in carbonite and Empire
it was considered an experiment years
later it appears this practice is caught
on with bounty hunters mana returns his
bounty to his guild leader grief targa
played by Carl Weathers the bounty
hunters guild was first mentioned in the
1998 novel the Mandalorian armor and has
since been mentioned another Star Wars
related materials grief mentions how
clients are paying beneath guild rates
side-effect of the Empire's collapse
since there's no longer a corrupt
central government to hire bounty
hunters to track people down grief pays
them half in Mon Calamari flan the
currency of Mon Cala the ocean covered
planet of Admiral Ackbar notice all the
credits make an extra wat exquisite
in the sound are a bunch of Star Wars
cameos including a few trend oceans
another Rodian outsider some Jawas and a
kawaki and monkey lizard roasting on a
spit while another one watches grimly
of course the species of salacious tea
crumb ain't laughing now grief sends
mando to a special client played by anna
her song is guarded by storm troopers
and bears an imperial crest pendant
suggesting he's an empire loyalist maybe
a former regional governor notice how
his stormtroopers are dirty his
residence a mess another detail
reflecting the Empire's collapse just
trying to hold on to what they had he
said you were the best into parsing the
client is referencing the famously
quoted parsec 12 of which the Millennium
Falcon famously completed the Kessel run
within do not do it speed but to its
advanced navigational system we learned
in solo it's another reminder that all
these guys are aware that it is the unit
of distance not time the client says
that the target is 50 years old and that
he's willing to take it dead or alive
though his companion wants it alive he
pays mando in the precious medal of best
scar it's stamped with the Imperial
crest from when it was looted from their
home planet semana returns to the
residents of other Mandalorians he heads
into the forage area marked with this
mythos our skull is an important history
to the skull but before we continue
thanks to honey for sponsoring this
breakdown as I've been doing some
holiday shopping online and some
shopping for myself it's kind of
annoying to see that field for promo
codes or discount codes left sadly empty
what am I missing out on could I have
saved a few bucks on this Han Solo in
carbonite rug honey is a free browser
extension that automatically finds the
best promo codes whenever you shop
online
that means you always get the best deals
without even trying on over 20,000 sites
such as Amazon eBay Walmart Best Buy
Target j.crew and more I went on Newegg
to buy some parts of my computer and
honey skin the internet in the
background to save me $110 and 59 cents
if you're wondering how I had the money
for a han Solo in carbonite rug there's
your answer
I am smoke honey only takes two clicks
to install and honey has found it's over
10 million members over a billion
dollars in savings
honey supports there were 20,000 stores
online and it is over 100 thousand five
star reviews on the google chrome store
so if you're buying gifts this holiday
season or buying yourself a nerdy Star
Wars merch then you need honey and if
you're not doing that you probably know
someone who is so Douma solid
and tell them about honey honey can make
sure that you're getting the best price
for whatever you're buying it's free to
use and installs in just two clicks get
honey for free at join honey calm slash
new rockstars has joined honey calm /
new rock stars
okay back to this skull the myth of
stars used to dominate the planet of
Mandalore until in ancient times they
were driven to extinction by the
Mandalorian tongue warriors led by
Mandalore the first later queel reminds
mando that his ancestors used to mount
these beasts this skull is a symbol of
the mend
allure the traditional ruler of all
Mandalorian clans now since their planet
was devastated from past warfare this
blacksmith may be the leader of all that
is left of the Mandalorian races they
try to rebuild their society mando
offers his profits over as tribute to
the community including the best score
brick which the Smith plans to use for
the younger foundlings but she makes
part of it into a new shoulder pauldron
to replace the one that got shot earlier
she asks if his signet has been revealed
and he says not yet perhaps signet
refers to his native plan with these
Mandalorian refugees trying to track
down which ancestral tribes each of them
were part of before the dark times of
the diaspora with each strike of the
blacksmith hammer mando is triggered
with memories of his past exile the
flashback ends with hatch closing over
him cut to mando now in his helmet as if
his armor keeps himself trapped in a
trauma that he was locked inside as a
boy mando travels and search for his new
mysterious bounty and he gets attacked
by blurbs these are the writing
creatures that were introduced in he
walks the Battle of Endor when the
blurred bites his arm it triggers the
flamethrower function just like the one
that the armor of boba and Jango Fett
had he's saved by a blurred Wrangler
quill an egg not played by Nick Nolte he
helps mando mount a blurred and points
them to this village where another
bounty hunter arrives ahead of him an
assassin droid IG 11 played by taiko
with TT via motion capture
he's a similar model as the ig-88 from
Empire and I just love how his bolts
form a face when they pivot around and
they're cornered his self-destruct
feature comes from a thermal detonator
in his chest similar to the ones that we
saw in past Star Wars films after
turning the guards and shooting IG 11
manda looks down at this bounty an
infant that is these same species as
Yoda whoa okay Yoda was 900 when he died
so 50 would still be a very young age
for this species until this point the
species was completely unknown but there
was another a female named gateau who
was on the
I counsel in the Phantom Menace maybe
Yoda and yeah it all had a history or
maybe these things grow out of cabbage
patches who knows we'll find out and
fifty years old and this being set in
nine ABY that would make its birth year
41 BBY which is the same year Anakin
Skywalker was born
perhaps the mythologized chosen one was
not Anakin Skywalker even Luke Skywalker
but actually this infant from Yoda's
species
check out the next episode of rogue
theory for all of our wild explanations
for what baby Yoda could be but by
putting this infant in the hands of this
gunslinger warrior the Mandalorian
series appears to be drawing from the
Japanese manga lone wolf and cub about a
Shogun executioner accompanying by his
three-year-old son would be fitting
because the original Star Wars was
heavily influenced by samurai mythology
with the word Jedi coming from Jedi
khaki the term first samurai period soap
operas what do you think this ending
means comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at Avis and follow new rock
stars and socials and subscribe to new
rockstars here on YouTube for breakdowns
of everything you love thank you for
watching I have spoken
[Music]